today we're talking about the Lenovo s10
mini netbook it's probably the best one
in its class and we gave it a 9 out of
10 and we're gonna explain why that is
it's actually the most powerful netbook
that we've tested so far was the only
one that was able to pass our benchmark
test which says and that kind of sets
the bar for us
I mean granted it's still low powered
it's ruining the Intel Atom processor
1.6 gigahertz like you know most
netbooks are but for some reason this
one just kind of tops it let's talk
quickly about the specs really quick so
it's 160 gigabyte hard drive that's the
biggest one out of all the netbooks that
are out there
one of the major downfalls of this
netbook for me is that it only lasts
about two hours at most and you know I
would want to be taking this thing to
the cafe a lot or just traveling a lot
and you know leaving my my premium
computer at home and bringing this thing
along and you know if this thing only
lasts two hours it's like how much can I
do with this how much how often I go
have to like bring the charger with me
to everywhere I go and it would be
interesting if this thing had a 6-cell
option 6 cell batteries usually lasts
around 4 hours 3 cells usually lasts
under two hours except that it would add
a little bit more weight to this thing
this thing I already waste 2.11 pounds
which isn't a lot but you know it's not
too ideal to go over three pounds I'd
say with these netbooks the MacBook Air
for example cut weighs three pounds and
that thing cause like what $1,800 but
it's much more powerful when three
pounds is okay for you know computer of
that caliber it's almost four times as
much so that's the things like you know
you're trying to figure out whether
you're willing to pay for that
performance or can you appreciate the
fact that is so mostly it's about four
hundred and fifty dollars you know I did
an interview with this guy Alan Kay who
was the first person who ever thought of
a laptop before you know back when
computers weighed like a hundred pounds
and had punch cards and everything and
30 40 years ago and yeah he advised the
Ignatian of a laptop and with cardboard
models and said you know they should be
two pounds and you know another thing
Kay said is that these netbooks are
still not powerful enough and there's
still a little bit too stripped down so
I think we're very close to getting
there
and this one especially is closer than
all the other ones we've tested but
we'll see I mean we'll see where the
word that goes yeah yeah I mean I would
love to see a cheap Mac netbook but
that's kind of like sci-fi at this point
hey you can't hack these though you
can't hack and put o Stan all these
things we're a couple of years away from
really powerful netbooks
with really good batteries in the
meantime this is probably the best one
that they have out there and we
recommend it with our manageable